bien chers collègues merci de de votre
présence
madame messieurs merci
je nous reprenons nos auditions dans le
cadre de la mission d'information sur
les émeutes qui sont survenus à la fin
du mois de juin dernier dans ce cycle
d'audition nous accueillons aujourd'hui
Madame Nathalie qui est sociologue
directrice de recherche au CNRS et
membre de l'Observatoire des ID
identitaire monsieur Marco Oberti qui
est également sociologue professeur en
sciences politiqu ancien directeur de
l'Observatoire sociologique du
changement et enfin Monsieur Thomas
saovadet également sociologue
spécialiste des bandes de jeunes
enseignant à l'université pariest
créteille madame monessieur merci de
d'être là nous avons à la commission des
lois mis en place cette mission
d'information de façon à aborder les
événements qui se sont passés d'une de
manière assez complète pas seulement sur
l'aspect sécuritaire c'est une chose sur
l'emploi des forces de l'ordre est une
est également une chose mais sur la
compr nous avons besoin de comprendre le
phénomène tel qu'il s'est passé car il
est'est pour nous pas habituel de voir
que dans certain quartiers où il se sont
plutôt calmes il y a eu des des dégâts
des bagarres enfin tout ce que vous
connaissez que dans d'autres où c'est
plutôt ça bouge un peu beaucoup c'était
plut calme enfin finalement les repères
que nous avons habituellement ne sont
pas ne sont pas au rendez-vous si je
puis dire pour faire très très simple et
très direct donc votre
éclairage nous est utile pour bien
comprendre la situation et nous
commettrons un rapport d'ici quelques
semaines quelques mois après que nous
ayons terminé l'ensemble de nos
auditions ce qui n'est pas fait je
précise aux collègues ainsi qu'à
vous-même que nous sommes retransmis en
direct sur le site internet du Sénat
voilà choses sont simples et comme
l'habitué mais les collègues le savent
je vais vous donner la parole un quart
d'heure chacun pour qu'on a 45 minutes
de présentation et après évidemment
chacun des collègues s'exprimera posera
des questions et on essaie de se
donner 1 heure 1 He3 d'horloge voilà si
à M qu4 on est disponible je crois que
ce sera bien pour tout le monde je veux
pas limiter le temps par principe mais
dans cette maison je connais un peu les
les risques qui que nous avons voilà et
bien écoutez je sais pas dans quel heord
vous avez prévu d'intervenir si vous
avez prévu quelque chose ou pas ou si je
suis
autoritaire Madame ou Monsieur alors
qu'est-ce qui vous préférez madame on va
faire l'ordre alphabétique bah très bien
allez je très bien ça marche ça marche
voilà donc je je précise d'abord que je
ne suis pas spécialiste des banlieu ni
de sociologie urbaine je vais m'appuyer
simplement non pas sur des enquête
personnelle donc mais sur des réflexions
issues de diverses lectures voilà euh je
voudrais insister d'abord sur le
caractère multiple des causalités hein
on a toujours tendance à vouloir trouver
une causalité principale voire unique et
je pense que c'est une grande erreur
donc je vais lister une série de
possibles causalités sans le le faire
par ordre d'importance mais simplement
pour essayer de balayer tout le spectre
he desib des possibilités
alors moi j'ai envie de commencer par
l'importance des réseaux sociaux j'y
reviendrai un peu plus tard mais je
pense que c'est absolument fondamental
aujourd'hui pour comprendre des
phénomènes collectifs puisque il donne
la possibilité technique d'accélérer
dans le temps la communication et aussi
de l'agrandir dans l'espace bon alors
évidemment on n' pas attendu les réseaux
sociaux pour avoir des émeutes urbaines
mais de cette dimension avec cette
rapidité de de contagion et cette
extension euh je pense que les réseaux
sociaux ils sont évidemment pour pour
beaucoup et aussi par la possibilité
qu'il donne de diffuser en direct des
images qui sont extrêmement frappantes
et qui sont susceptibles d'entraîner une
sorte de contagion des actes hein là il
y a tout toutes sortes de de travaux en
psychologie sociale sur l'incitation à
l'action via la banalisation de
certaines images notamment des images de
violence et là je pense que les réseaux
sociaux ont évidemment une énorme
responsabilité alors faut-il envisager
interdire que l'on offre des des
smartphones aux enfants avant
l'adolescence personnellement je serais
pour cette mesure mais bon ça c'est à
voilà c'est à discuter deuxème causalité
euh on a bien sûr de façon inhérante à
toute immigration des phénomènes de
regroupement communautairire qui peuvent
favoriser des formes de coopération dans
la transgression euh et on ne peut y euh
on ne peut y répondre me semble
semble-t-il que par une tentative pour
contrer ces regroupements par une
politique urbaine ciblée c'est ce dont
il a été question très récemment avec
les mesures présenté par le Premier
ministre mais s'ajoute à ce phénomène
traditionnel propre à toute immigration
une forme de ghtoisation dû à
l'urbanisme des cités qui est donc
propre à l'immigration récente alors que
l'immigration traditionnelle de
centre-ville permettait beaucoup plus le
mélange social et là on a vraiment une
forme de de gettoisation liée à
évidemment une gestion extrêmement
problématique des des des formes de
l'immigration depuis disons les deux
dernières générations il me semble que
pour casser ce phénomène de ghetto il
serait bon de favoriliser les
internats ce qui permettrait d'éloigner
des enfants soumis à un environnement
familial et de proximité problématique
mais là encore ça je je j'essaie de
suggérer des pistes de solution hein
mais je voilà c'est c'est pas moi de de
dire ce qu'il faut faire mais je me dis
que ce serait une façon de de casser
cette logique de kettoisation il y a
également il en a été beaucoup question
je n'en suis pas spécialiste mais il
faut le rappeler le la question de la du
démantellement de la police de proximité
depuis près d'une génération on sait les
maintenant je pense assez bien les les
effets pervers de cette mesure et
peut-être faudrait-il revenir sur cette
fameuse réforme Sarkozy peut-être
faudrait-il aussi euh
faire en sorte qu'il y ait des primes
pour attirer dans les quartiers les
policiers les plus expérimentés et non
pas y amener les plus jeunes pour des
raisons toutes bêtes he de de de
progression dans la hiérarchie là encore
je ne suis pas spécialiste mais il me
semble que il y a il y a une piste à à
explorer on a bien sûr lié à cette
question policière le rôle des trafics
qui entraîne une forme de délégitimation
de la loi qui me paraît aussi très
problématique faut-il dépénaliser
l'usage du cannabis je laisseel votre
réflexion mais en tout cas là il y a
évidemment un sujet énorme il y a
également ça a été moins dit je pense
dans les commentaires après les émeutes
un problème de démantellement du tissu
associatif
socioculturel notamment depuis les
années 1980 et les changements dans la
distribution des compétences entre le
ministère de la Culture et le ministère
de la jeunesse et là euh je crois qu'il
y a aussi un énorme problème euh qui euh
pourrait peut-être se euh s'amander en
favorisant à nouveau ce que ce qui a été
fait ce qui avait été fait dans
l'aprèsgerre les associations locales et
surtout en contrôlant strictement leurs
activités de façon à éviter les
enrôlements idéologique et religieux
parce qu'on sait maintenant que une
bonne partie des associations de
jeunesse notamment des associations
sportives ont fait l'objet d'un
anentrisme massif euh par les islamistes
et notamment par les Frères musulmans et
donc là je me semble-t-il des une prise
de conscience et des mesures très
importantes à prendre toujours sur la
question de l'éducation
euh qu'en est-il de l'éducation
nationale bon c'est un énorme chantier
je je ferais que qu'indiquer trois
pistes là encore de même que pour la
police de proximité euh il a été
beaucoup dit et ça me semble judicieux
qu'il faudrait des primes pour attirer
dans les quartiers les enseignants les
plus expérimentés et non' pas envoyé au
cas pipe les les plus jeunes bon euh il
faudrait me semble-t-il et là aussi ça a
été suggéré ouvrir les établissements
scolaires au-delà des heures
d'enseignement proprement dit et d'avoir
des des heures de euh de de d'études
obligatoires pour que pour éviter que
des jeunes traînent dans la rue au lieu
de pouvoir faire leurs devoirs dans des
conditions satisfaisantes euh moi il me
semble que ce serait une une mesure de
bon sens euh je note aussi le dénis qui
a été longtemps pratiqué au sein de
l'éducation nationale en matière
d'antisémitisme et de ségrégation
scolaire qui avait été parfaitement
repéré au début des années 2000 d'une
part par l'ouvrage collectif dirigé par
je George benensoussan les territoires
perdus de la République et d'autre part
la par le rapport auain et les deux
ayant été soigneusement enterrés ce qui
nous revient dans la figure aujourd'hui
me semble-t-il bon alors je vais
maintenant revenenir à quelque chose PE
pe-êre d'un peu plus général et qui n'a
peut-être pas beaucoup été dit euh et
qui qui qui qui renvoie une tribune que
j'avais publié dans le monde en novembre
2020 après l'assassinat de Samuel
paatti et et qui s'intitulé le le qui
était disons consacré à la question du
processus de décivilisation lié
notamment à la politique de l'enfantroi
bon on a un modèle éducatif qui s'est
développé à partir des des années 70
probablement pour d'excellentes raisons
de disons de favoriser la liberté
individuelle l'écoute envers les besoins
des enfants mais qui a des effets
pervers et dans parmi ces effets pervers
que nous subissons aujourd'hui parce que
une génération voire deux générations
après on se retrouve avec une forme de
de de de rapport à la loi qui s'est
répandu et qui me semble très
problématique puisque
cette tique de l'enfantroi abouti à
développer une mentalité disons de toute
puissance du Briss de refus de toute
contrainte de considérer que toute forme
de contrainte sur la liberté
individuelle est forcément négative et
forcément
insupportable de focalisation sur les
droits au détriment des devoirs de
fétichisation de la liberté individuelle
au détriment de l'intérêt général ce qui
me semble être un effet pervers de la
libération des meœurs depuis deux
générations libéralisation que nous
pouvons
pouvion approuver mais dont nous voyons
aujourd'hui des effets pervers et c'est
ce que j'ai proposer de
nommer en m'appuyant sur un sociologue
qui m'est cher Norbert Elias le
processus de décivilisation alors
qu'est-ce que Norbert Elias entendait
par ce terme il entendait un processus
qui défait progressivement ce qu'il
avait longuement étudié dans ses travaux
à travers le à savoir le processus de
civilisation des meurs c'est àd de
progressive acquisition d'une d'un
autocontrôle d'une autocontrainte sur
ses propres pulsions qui fait partie du
de donc de ce que elas' appelit le
processus de civilisation du monde
occidental qui aboutit à toutes sortes
de de de conséquences que je ne vais pas
préciser parce que ce serait trop long
mais qui qui qui qui définit aujourd'hui
les fondements du cadre de la civilité
hein sur le le fait de contrôler ses
émotions de contrôler ses C tendance à
la violence euh et cetera bon or Elias
lui-même a noté que ce processus n'est
pas
irréversible et que il peut euh se
retourner par moment dans des moments de
régression où c'est non plus la
civilisation mais la décivilisation qui
intervient et cette
décivilisation elle se manifeste
notamment par cette ce desserrement de
l'autocontrôle et cette possibilité de
euh de de passer à l'acte de façon
violente de façon pulsionnelle et je
pense que ces émeutes en ont donné un
exemple tout à fait tout à fait évident
alors Jérôme pour Fourquet a repris dans
son dernier livre cette notion du
processus de décivilisation
a été repris il a été repris également
vous le savez par Emmanuel Macron ça a
été très contesté par certains
sociologues mais je pense que là il y a
vraiment une piste importante et je
reviens à ce propos sur la question des
réseaux sociaux qui sont évidemment une
une incitation à cette décivilisation
notamment parce que en
favorisant des
expressions libres sans contrainte et
notamment sans la contrainte de
l'interaction en face à face que nous
avons lorsque nous sommes physiquement
face à quelqu'un lorsque nous sommes à
distance que nous ne voyons pas la
personne dont nous parlons ou à qui nous
nous adressons ça favorise évidemment
des phénomènes de de de des faire par
lement de haine de d'insulte de violence
et cetera de sentiment d'une sorte de
toute-puissance he de non contrôle de ce
qui se dit et je pense que pour cette
raison purement technique les les
réseaux sociaux sont un facteur très
fort de
décivilisation je voudrais
aussi insister sur quelque chose qui
n'est pas politiquement correct mais je
pense qu'il faut le dire c'est que dans
la culture musulmane il y a un prix
privilège traditionnel accordé aux
garçons hein qui sont un peu ces
adolescents rois à à qui l'on ne refuse
rien contrairement évidemment aux filles
et cela a été très bien décrit par des
ethnologues et notamment par Germain
Tyon dans un magnifique livre que je
vous recommande qui s'intitule le harem
et les cousins qui est un livre déjà
ancien mais qui décrivait parfaitement
cette culture propre au monde musulman
et qui aujourd'hui me paraît tout à fait
présente dans cette euh c'est cette ce
sentiment de toute puissance et de non
régulation de ces pulsions violentes que
l'on trouve beaucoup pour beaucoup chez
des adolescents issus de l'immigration
donc ça ça n ça n'est pas très
politiquement correct de le dire
aujourd'hui mais je pense que c'est très
important à à souligner alors il me
semble que ça pourrait être en partie
modéré par une éducation scolaire à
l'égalité entre fills et garçons ça nous
paraît aller de soi mais je pense qu'il
faudrait que l'école très très tôt
insiste sur l'importance de prendre au
sérieux cette question de l'égalité
entre fills et garçons pour que au moins
les filles dans ses familles puissent
dire oui mais vous m'imposez ça mais ça
n'est pas conforme hein au aux lois et
aux règles de de du pays dans lequel
nous vivons donc voilà les différentes
causalités et pour finir je voudrais
simplement terminer sur une précision
c'est que nous avons été une dizaine de
sociologues à avoir cossigné au mois
d'août une tribune parue dans l'Obs pour
nous opposer à une déclaration faite au
Congrès des sociologues de l'Association
Française de Sociologie le 17 juillet
2023 à l'occasion de ce de son 10e
congrès une motion donc adoptée en
assemblée générale intitulé sur les
révoltes en cours dans les quartiers
populaires et qui apporte son soutien je
cite aux revendications légitime qui
émane des quartiers populaires Vérité
Justice et égalité qui dénonce les
violences toujours je cite hein les
violences policières systémiques
s'indignent contre la justice expéditive
et la répression judiciaire lourde à
laquelle nous assistons depuis plusieurs
jours et s'inquiète de la montée de
l'extrême droite fin de citation donc
nous nous protestiontions dans cette
tribune contre le fait que cette motion
adopté par quelques personnes hein euh
ne dit rien sur les violences commises
par les émetiers sur les actes
d'intimidation et les voix de faê
perpétré contre des édyes sur le sacage
des biens publics et des commerces qui
constituent les moyens d'existence d'une
partie de la population de ces quartiers
nous voilà donc face à un parfait
exemple de militantisme académique qui
pratique ouvertement la confusion des
arènes entre la science et la politique
et donc le dévoiement de la recherche et
de l'enseignement supérieur et il me
semble que ces dérives que j'ai nommé
académo militante et bien il serait plus
que tant que la représentation nationale
s'y penche parce qu'elles sont
gravissimes pour ce qui est de
l'Enseignement supérieur et de la
Recherche je vous remercie
merci beaucoup madame je don la parole à
Monsieur Saad ou
monsieur par
alphabétiqueabétique pardon le principe
jeava oublié merci bonjour merci pour
pour
l'invitation en fait moi je vais vous
proposer une perspective bien bien
différente de celle de de ma collègue
puisque j'ai travaillé aussi sur les
émeutes de 2005 et donc essayer de
d'utiliser cette comparaison avec un
épisode qui a été peut-être moins
violent mais plus long et qui permet de
voir des choses assez intéressantes en
terme d'enquête alors je pense qu'il est
important aussi de revenir sur l'élément
déclencheur puisque il semble
apparemment le même c'est-à-dire en 2005
la la mort de deux jeunes très jeunes
hommes 15 et 17 ans qui tentent
d'échapper à la police et qui sont
électrocutés à clichis sousbois et à
Nanterre Naël 17 ans également qui en
tentant aussi d'échapper enfin après une
course poursuite avec la police est
arrêté et est tué d'une balle dans le
thorax par un policier alors pourquoi
euh donc là il y a une similitude et en
même temps il va y avoir une vraie
différence qui a d'ailleurs été indiquée
par ma collègue sur ensuite le rôle des
réseaux sociaux qui est qu'à la
différence de 2005 hein je vous rappelle
qu'en 2005 aucun de ces réseaux sociaux
n'existait snapchat Instagram TikTok et
cetera aucun n'existait en 2005 donc là
qu'est-ce qui se passe c'est que non
seulement la scène est filmée elle est
diffusée massivement et rapidement sur
les réseaux sociaux mais elle vient
démentir la première version policière
proposée et ça ça ça c'est c'est
essentiel c'est-à-dire que ça va être
très vite interprété de deux façons
comme l'impunité de la police relié à
des à des violences policières et voir
dans ce cas précislà et en référence à
2005 à une dimension raciste de de
l'acte policier premier point et surtout
euh il se trouve que moi j'étais à
Nanterre à ce moment-là j'habite
nantherre et il se trouve aussi que
beaucoup de de personnes à ce moment-là
se posent la question y compris des
jeunes mais que ce serait-il passé si
nous avions eu la possibilité de
visionner la plupart des scènes de cette
nature là est-ce qu'elles auraient
montrer des versions différentes de
celle officielle proposé par la police
et ça bien évidemment c'est plus qu'une
étincelle vous pouvez le comprendre
alors je vais pas je vais pas développer
la question des réseaux sociaux vous
l'avez indiqué rapidement
mais il y a vraiment tout un travail à
faire sur cette dimensionl et peut-être
que vous avez prévu dans les séances
d'audition d'impliquer des collègues qui
sont je pense à certains de mes
collègues à sciencep qui sont vraiment
des spécialistes de de l'analyse des
réseaux sociaux et en particulier dans
le lien avec la mobilisation collective
des mouvements sociaux et dans et dans
ce cas-là les émeutes mais donc
j'insiste sur cette fausse similitude à
à différents points de vue avec
l'élément déclencheur de 2000 5 ensuite
il y a un autre élément intéressant qui
est que en terme géographique et
temporel on va assister à quelque chose
de différent par rapport à 2005 c'estàd
qu'il y a presque deux temps et je vais
essayer de de de le de les présenter
très rapidement même si je suis en train
de on est en train avec une collègue de
travailler sur l'article de façon plus
approfondie il y a un premier temps qui
est essentiellement que moi je vais
qualifié d'émotionnel et qui est très
lié à ce que je viens de vous raconter
sur la scène qui est filmée et qui vient
démentir la première version de la
police d'accord et qui est
essentiellement franilienne
banlieupisienne et trèsvite lyonaise
très très peu les petites villes et les
villes moyennes et donc là d'ailleurs y
compris en dehors des temps nocturnes ce
temps-là va agréger pas simplement des
jeunes des militants des éducateurs des
adultes des des des élus différentes
catégories de personnes qui vont être
choqués parce que parce que révèle la
scène qui qui a été filmé et diffusé sur
les réseaux sociaux et donc je dis
tempant émotionnel parce que il touche
des personnes au-delà de simplement la
catégorie des ce qu'on appelle des
jeunes des quartiers en difficulté et et
ce temps-là je le répète il est aussi il
va être très court hein je je vous
renvoie l'article qui a été publié sur
le site de la vie des idées et sur le
site de scienceces PO dans une version
plus longue on voit bien si on on
revient au donné que c'est c'est très
vite beaucoup de communes beaucoup
d'événements en île-de-fance et ça chute
très vite et ce sont les petites villes
et les villes moyennes qui vont prendre
le relais et donc dans ce temps-là il
est à la fois très banlieux très court
très intense et très émotionnel le
deuxième temps il est un peu différent
de mon point de vue il arrive quelques
nuits après il touche principalement
mais pas uniquement des petites villes
et des villes moyennes et c'est plutôt
un temps alors j'ai pas trouvé j'ai pas
de bons terme pour le qualifier parce
que dans un premier temps je je l'ai
qualifié de temps insurrectionnel mais
c'est pas c'est pas exactement ce que je
veux dire il s'agit pas de le réduire un
temps insurrectionnel ce que je veux
dire par là c'est que et on le voit à
travers aussi l'analyse qualitative
d'autres matériaux que le rapport avec
la mort en tant que telle de Maë et les
conditions dans lesquelles naë a été tué
et Mo est plus ténu c'est-à-dire que et
il y a quelque chose qui va mettre en
jeu des mêmes facteurs structurels mais
qui du point de vue du rapport à
l'événement lui même est un peu
différent et là ce qui est intéressant
aussi c'est que en terme de registre de
violence on change un tout petit peu de
registre c'est-à-dire qu'on va être
beaucoup plus que que c'est c'est aussi
le cas dans le premier temps mais
beaucoup plus dans le deuxième temps sur
des du pillage du saccage de de commerce
et cetera donc on va être un tout petit
peu moins sur des questions de
dégradation de biens publics que ce soit
des institutions associé à la police euh
au gouvernements locaux ou ou à
l'échelle régionale ou nationale on va
être beaucoup plus sur de de la
destruction de de bien privé et de
sacage et pillage de commerce mais ce
que je voudrais dire c'est que dans les
deux cas donc on le voit à la fois à
travers l'analyse des statistiques
descriptives et mais aussi à travers
l'analyse de statistiques plus plus
sophistiqué à partir de régression
linéaire ou logistique il y a quelque
chose d'intéressant qui ressort de de de
ces analyses là premier point si vous
voulez je vais essaie de le dire
rapidement parce que ça ça prendrait
trop de temps de rentrer dans le détail
des traitements
statistiques premier point plus que la
présence de locataire HLM immigrés
pauvreté familles nombreuses
suroccupation des logements et cetera et
cetera je vais pas vous faire toute la
liste des variables qu'on a mis dans les
modèles de régression mais plus que la
présence de de de ces indicateurs là ou
la les fortes valeurs de ces indicateurs
là c'est le leur concentration dans
quelques quartiers spécifiques qui
expliqueent le mieux la probabilité de
connaître une émeute de façon très très
nette donc encore une fois et ça on le
contrôle très bien puisque on a aussi
établi des scores à l'échelle de
l'ensemble des communes de française
concernant tous les indicateurs que je
vous ai cité et en rajoutant ensuite un
indicateur qui est un proxy à la
question de la ségrégation très forte
dans des espaces très délimités de tous
ces indicateurs qui est le fait d'avoir
ou non un quartier prioritaire de la
politique de la ville et quand on
intègre cette variable là ça capte tout
le reste et c'est ultra significatif se
fois plus toute chose égal par ailleurs
c'estàd contrôlé par toutes les
variables que je vous ai cité se fois
plus de chance de connaître une émeute
plutôt que de ne pas en connaître c'est
très fort en terme d' ratio et de
régression logistique très fort donc
j'insiste là-dessus et et encore une
fois on j'ai pas le temps de rentrer
dans le détail sur on pourrait prendre
des exemples précis hein de villes de
petit de villes peties et moyennes qui
ont toutes les caractéristiques au sens
de des indicateurs que j'ai cité pour
connaître une émeute et qui n'en ont pas
connu parce que souvent elles n'ont pas
de qpv et le qpv c'est une façon à ce
stade là de la recherche d'indiquer un
degré de concentration de ségrégation
dans l'espace de toutes ces
caractéristiques là alors ensuite le
deuxième élément intéressant quand on
pousse l'analyse statistique c'est de
dissocier qui s'est passé en région
parisienne dans les banlieux de la de la
de la métropole parisienne des petites
villes et des villes moyennes dont j'ai
déjà parlé et ce qui est intéressant là
aussi et et c'est ça pose des problèmes
d'ailleurs méthodologiques sur le plan
statistique puisque moi j'avais
l'indicateur est-ce que ces communesl
parmi l'ensemble des communes de La
banliue Parisienne quelles étaient
celles qui avaient connu aussi des
émeutes en 2005 et quand on fait rentrer
cette variable là dans le modèle de
régression pareil paf ça absorbe
beaucoup de choses et ça multiplie les
probabilités de connaître une émeute en
2023 alors comment qu'est-ce que ça veut
dire euh quand on essaie d'interpréter
ce résultat- làà ça veut dire aussi et
et moi je voudrais insister sur cette
dimensionl que il y a maintenant une
mémoire collective des émeutes dans
beaucoup de banlieux et en particulier
des banlieux des plus grandes métropole
française c'est pas simplement 2005
c'est une succession d'événements qui
marque la la la la vie locale et qui
marque aussi les expériences politiques
des des des personnes qui participent de
près ou de loin à ces émeutes et qu'il y
a là me semble-t-il une différence très
forte entre cette mémoire collective qui
devient très structurante dans les
banlieux des grandes métropoles versus
la la la faible présence de cette
mémoire collective dans les petites
villes les villes moyennes dont je vous
ai parlé et je vous reparlerai du lien
avec les gilets jaunes après donc
qu'est-ce qui se passe c'est-à-dire que
il faut bien voir que cette cette
mémoire elle est aussi portée par et làâ
je relativiste qui a été dit
précédemment par le fait que dans si on
regarde sur plusieurs décennies il y a
dans dans ces dans ces quartiers
c'està-dire les quartiers en difficulté
des grandes banlieu des métropoles il y
a un tissu associatif qui a une longue
histoire maintenant et qui et qui s'est
renouvelé et qui porte aujourd'hui à
juste titre par juste titre un discours
très fort de lutte contre les
discriminations et donc le fait aussi
que dans ces quartiers-là un tissu
associatif se mobilise essaie de de de
donner une forme à ses revendications et
à une sorte de conscience de l'intensité
de certaines discriminations ça
participe aussi des dynamiques
émeutières dans la région parisienne
c'est pas le cas dans les petites villes
et villes moyennes je ne dis pas que
dans les quartiers les plus paupérisés
de ces petites villes et ville moyenne
il n'y a pas de tissu associatif qui
porte une sorte de conscience du point
de vue de la lutte contre les
discriminations mais il est beaucoup
moins fort et il irigue beaucoup moins
ces quartiers que dans les les les
quartiers prioritaires de la politique
de la ville des grandes métropoles donc
là et et donc là là là il y a quel c'est
assez cohérent avec ce que je vous ai
dit précédemment c'est-à-dire que ça à
voir avec la distinction entre le temps
émotionnel et le temps
insurrectionnel puisque là on retrouve
quelque chose qui a à voir avec ce que
j'essaie de de vous présenter enfin je
voudrais terminer sur enfin sur sur deux
point
du côté des petites villes et des villes
moyennes ce qui est intéressant c'est
que quand on essaie de rattacher ces
petites villes et villes moyennes
touchées par les émeutes au
rassemblement de 2018 des gilets jaunes
ça se superpose assez bien pas
parfaitement mais quand même mais bien
évidemment ne me faites pas dire ce que
je n'ai pas dit ce ne sont pas les mêmes
populations et c'est ça qui est
intéressant on retrouve des mêmes
territoires assez papérisés en situation
périphérique sur beaucoup d'aspects qui
dans certains qui en 2018 par rapport à
un certain contexte vont donner lieu à
des mobilisations très fortes occupation
des rond-points et voir des formes plus
spontanées et violentes de revendication
mais qui touch des des enfin qui sont
ancrés dans ces territoires là mais qui
touchent des populations spécifiques et
on retrouve en 2023 des petites villes
et villes moyennes qui sont les mêmes
mais qui qui ne mettent pas en jeu les
mêmes catégories de population
et je pense que ça ça mérite de s'y
arrêter et et et ça appelle d'autres
d'autres analyses enfin travaillant
depuis maintenant pas mal de temps sur
la ségrégation scolaire je suis en train
de terminer aussi un autre rapport sur
la ségrégation
scolaire je ne peux pas m'empêcher de
faire le lien avec cette question là
alors on a créé un indicateur enfin
trois indicateurs en fait sur à partir
de la base de données que sur laquelle
nous travaillons actuellement qui
consiste à coder 01 pour une commune
s'il y a ou non une école au moins une
école qui par qui qui fait partie du
décile le le plus faible de l'indice de
position sociale c'est-à-dire qui a on
va le dire simplement qui a au moins une
école très défavorisée et on a complété
ça avec l'écart type qui nous dit
quelque chose sur le degré de mixité ou
de ségrégation de l'école l'effet la
significativité de cette variable y
compris associé à
qpv dans les deux cas est très
significatif donc voyez parce que moi
j'en ai un petit peu assez je vous le
dis sincèrement quand on me demande
toujours depuis sachant que je travaille
sur les émeutes et la ségrégation
urbaine et scolaire mais pourquoi est-ce
qu'il crame les écoles pourquoi est-ce
qu'il brûlent les écoles bah il y a il
faut aussi se poser la question de
qu'est-ce que produit décennies après
décennies la ségrégation scolaire et pas
simplement la ségrégation résidentielle
et donc le c'est ce ce qu'il faut bien
voir c'est que pour une partie des
jeunes l'expérience qu'ils ont de
l'école c'est une expérience d'échec
voir d'humiliation et de rejet et
l'école je dis bien l'école plus que le
collège c'est l'institution de proximité
par excellence si on regarde d'un point
de vue cartographique si on géolocalise
en terme d'institution publique celles
qui sont les plus proches des quartiers
en question je parle pas des collèges he
parce qu'il y a des sectorisations plus
là de l'école c'est l'institution qui
est la plus proche et donc je suis pas
en train encore une fois ne me faites
pas dire ce que je ne dis pas moi je
suis sociologue je parle pas de jugement
de valeur je regarde des faits et
j'essaie de les interprétter et donc
quand je je constate à partir de travaux
socio-statistique une approche
socioterritoriale qu'il y a quand même
des éléments contextuels qui sont
récurrents structurants et sur lesquels
on agit quand même relativement peu ben
ça ça donne à penser de façon plus large
sur ce qu'il serait possible d'envisager
en terme de politique publique si on
veut véritablement lutter euh contre
l'apparition des émeutes merci merci
beaucoup monsieur Monsieur Thomas
Sauvanet bonjour donc j'ai j'ai
travaillé depuis euh depuis la fin des
années 90 sur sur les quartiers de la
politique de la ville notamment en
banlieu parisienne euh l'une des
information euh importante c'est qu'en
travaillant sur sur ces quartiers euh
j'ai mis quelques années à à réaliser
que en fait les les jeunes qu'on voyait
dans la rue et qui étaient appelés les
jeunes souvent par les travailleurs
sociaux ou par des habitants ou par des
élus locaux ne ne représentai en fait
qu'une minorité de la jeunesse locale ça
a l'air tout bête mais quand tout le
monde dit les jeunes les jeunes les
jeunes les jeunes euh et ben on baigne
dans une sorte de de de représentation
du sens commun et euh voilà donc j'ai
travaillé à partir de là essayer de
recenser euh dans différents qpv euh les
jeunes qui se présentaient comme les
jeunes du quartier et qui étit présenté
par des acteurs
associatifs ou des habitants comme étant
les jeunes du quartier et je suis arrivé
à peu près à une représentation un
pourcentage qui qui tournait autour de
de 10 % euh des jeunes de sexe masculin
même si les filles ont un un un rôle à
jouer sont parfois présentes de moins de
30 ans avec des des des groupes euh à la
fois d'enfants qui sont très vite
repérés et et et représentés comme les
futurs acteurs importants des des bandes
du quartier euh des préadolescents des
adolescents et des des jeunes adultes et
c'est une socialisation en fait juvénil
euh ou avec des formes d'éducation
multigénérationnelle mais où il y a très
peu d'adultes en fait hein il y a très
peu d'encadrement adulte et on a des des
des des connexions entre différents
groupes d'enfants d'adolescents et de
jeunes adultes avec des des interactions
et et des transmissions de de
savoir-faire de euh de savoir-être avec
du contrôle social également euh ces euh
ces 10 % qui représentent à peu près à
peu près une centaine parfois un peu
moins parfois parfois un peu plus euh
d'enfants d'adolescents et et de jeunes
adultes se socialisent dans des dans des
bandes et à partir des des années 90
dans des réseau de trafic alors tous ne
sont pas dans des bandes ou des réseaux
de trafic mais c'est vraiment les les
formes structurantes les les
organisations soci structurante de cette
vie juvénile dans l'espace public dans
les qpv la différence avec les bandes et
ça c'est quelque chose qui est souvent
peu pris en compte par les travailleurs
sociaux les enseignants les éducateurs
de la PJJ c'est que la la bande n'est
pas un simple groupe de paèir la
différence entre un groupe de pair et
une bande c'est qu'il y a une dynamique
transgressive et une appropriation de
l'espace la bande se caractérise par le
regroupement de d'adolescents souvent pr
adolescen voir même d'enfants qui ont
beaucoup de de difficultés ult sociale
familiale scolaire plus tard plus tard
professionnel mais qui en se réunissant
ces garçons en se réunissant développent
une sorte de pouvoir de puissance qui
est lié à la puissance collective du
groupe et qui passe par l'appropriation
de l'espace j'ai notamment été frappé
dans les années 90 par un un un jeune
qui allait devenir millionnaire grâce au
trafic de cannabis et qui avait même une
appropriation de l'espace privé c'est
veut dire qu'il disait eNOS les gens
habitent ici parce que on le veut bien
donc les gens faut qu' faut qu'ils se
rendent compte que c'est nous qui
validons en quelque sorte les dossiers
du bailleur et et donc je j'étais frappé
à la fin des années 90 par cette
déclaration qui était froide qui était
calme qui faisait suite à une
altercation avec une habitante du de
l'immeuble qui était sortie pour se
plaindre du
bruit sur un la nuit un tapage tapage
nocturne et j'avais été frappé par le
par le calme par la la confiance en soi
et et un sentiment d'appropriation et de
légitimité qui s'exprimait avec beaucoup
de de force et beaucoup de tranquillité
et cette appropriation de de de l'espace
vient vient
heurter les habitants les commerçants
les les acteurs
associatifs avec une forme de sélection
là récemment je travaill dans un dans un
qpv de banlieu parisienne où on avait
plusieurs bandes de jeunes qui se
vantaient d'avoir choisi le gardien donc
il y avait eu plusieurs démissions
plusieurs gardiens qui avait démissionné
il se vantait d'avoir choisi le gardien
de de la cité ça devient compliqué en
fait pour beaucoup d'adultes habitants
commerçants gardiens euh travailleurs
sociaux euh d'avoir juste des mots qui
jugent ce ces ces jeunes là donc il a il
y a une la liberté de parole si vous
voulez ça il faut vraiment en en prendre
conscience quand on demande à à une mère
de famille à un animateur du service
jeunesse que pensez-vous de ceci que
pensez-vous de cela il sait dans la
plupart des cas qu'il sera reconnu euh
bon maintenant il demande parfois à être
flouté à témoigner de manière anonyme
mais il sait qu'il sera reconnu qu'il
sera qu'il sera vu avec des conséquences
qui vont soit du boycott c'est-à-dire
des jeunes qui disent on on parle plus à
ces animateurs on parle plus à ce
commerçant on parle plus et ils font
pression sur les autres jeunes qui
subissent au quotidien ces ces groupes
des formes de boycott et puis bien sûr
aussi des formes de de représaill euh
les représailles sont sont sont
relativement rare en fait car il n'y a
même pas besoin en faitd que le rapport
de force aujourd'hui est tellement à
l'avantage de de de ces groupes là que
qui est assez stupide pour créer un
conflit avec ces groupes là donc il il y
a même des quartiers où il y a pas de
conflit et l'absence de conflit en fait
est est problèmatique c'est justement
l'absence de conflit qui qui qui doit
qui doit nous nous
inquiéter c'est ces groupes ces groupes
qui sont qui sont qui sont dans ces
quartiers et qui se sont développés
notamment euh en vieillissant
c'est-à-dire avec des vieux jeunes qui
ont constitué des vieilles bandes et des
des qui sont entrés dans des réseaux de
trafic euh c'est moins le rajeunissement
en fait hein de de de ces bandes que le
vieillissement de ces bandes qui posent
problème aujourd'hui avec des jeunes
adultes de 20 ans 25 ans 30 ans 35 ans
qui sont toujours dans cette forme de
socialisation et qui ont bien sûr une
influence sur sur les plus jeunes qui
peuvent à la fois les pousser à
l'émeutes mais aussi parfois dans
d'autres circonstances les dissuadé de
recourir à ce type de de pratique
ametière ce ce ce ce ce collectif alors
qui quiass ces divisions qui qui est pas
qui est pas qui est pas structuré il y a
plusieurs réseaux plusieurs bandes euh
mais ce ce
c'est ce ces jeunes qui sont dans la rue
qui sont dans des dans dans des groupes
depuis depuis la la fin des années 80 on
ont eu une montée en puissance qu'on
peut qu'on peut qualifié de différentes
façons économique culturelle guerrière
et
politique une montée en puissance
économique qui est beaucoup lié au
trafic de stupéfiants et notamment au
trafic de cannabis qui se développe à
partir du milieu des années 90 et qui va
transformer certaines bandes en réseau
de trafic qui fait qu'aujourd'hui on a
du grand banditisme comme un anre par
exemple euh dans des cités dans des
quartiers résidentiel populaires qui
n'ont jamais connu de grand banditisme
grand banditisme plutôt des quartiers où
il y a de l'argent un Pigal le panier où
il y a du où il y a des activités
commerciales il y a un port il a et
cetera mais pas des quartiers d'ouvriers
de de de petits employés de de chômeurs
qui sont des quartiers résidentiels le
trafic de stupéfiant a changé a changé
la donne et on a vu apparaître des dans
certains quartiers
euh y compris dans par exemple on a été
très étonné avec Redwan FID par exemple
qui venait de la ville de crille dans
l'Oise donc la police judiciaire était
étonné effectivement de de voir des
profils comme le sien émergé dans sur
des territoires comme comme celui-là euh
même si lui était pas lié au trafic de
stup il était lié au au braquage monté
en puissance culturel aussi c'estàd
qu'avec le rap et l'identification
ghetto américain ils ont développé un
imaginaire euh plus ou moins relié au au
au au ghetto américain
euh lorsque j'étais jeune il y avait
souvent une blague qui était de dire bon
tu fais l'Américain quoi c'est tu en
fais trop quoi en quelque sorte euh
cette cette ce sorte cette sorte de
contrôle social qui qui qui qui vise à à
à à à dire que l'identification au au
ghetto américains et au gang américains
est est trop forte a petit à petit cédé
et on l'a vu notamment dans le rap avec
l'émergence du Gangstar rap et
aujourd'hui avec des rappeurs Gangstar
qui sont vraiment enfin qui sont
quasiment à l'image des des rappeurs
Gangstar américains et qui sont devenus
vraiment des vedettes du showbusiness
des stars du showbsiness et qu' ont une
influence sociale euh et qu'on développé
un mouvement culturel avec des modes
vestimentaires avec des codes arg
gothique
avec avec donc une musique qui
aujourd'hui est un
peu une culture largement partagé qu'on
retrouve y compris dans des villages ou
dans des des des villes ou des des des
petites villes ou des des moyennes
villes c'est devenu une culture juvénile
de de référence et on la retrouve même
parfois même dans les dans les dans les
villes ou dans les quartiers dans les
beaux quartiers dans les lycées chic par
exemple parisien ou y compris dans des
dans des familles des classes
supérieures certains je durant
l'adolescence s'identifie à cette à
cette culture
là guerrière puisque l'argent en fait du
du du trafic de stupéfiants a amené
aussi le trafic d'armes et on a vu des
quartiers à corbeille à Nanterre à
champign bien sûr à Marseille à Grenoble
et un peu partout je vous rappelle que
avant les émeutes de de juin juuillet
ont parlait beaucoup de la banisation
des ce qu'on appelle des règlements de
compte liés au trafic de stupéfiants
dans des villes qui n'avaient jamais
connu ce type de violence type Rafal à
la kalashnikov et cetera donc cette
actualité là a été chassée par une autre
actualité qui a été celle celle des
émeut il y a les armes à feu et aussi au
niveau des pratiques émeutières ou même
de contrôle du territoire avec une une
violence de basse intensité on a par
exemple la diffusion des mortiers
d'artifice qui a aussi changé y compris
au niveau des images et des réseaux
sociaux euh aussi à la fois au niveau du
spectacle mais aussi en terme en terme
de capacité d'action euh politique en
fait aussi parce que les émeutes ont
amené aussi des élus locaux des
associations des travailleurs sociaux à
se mobiliser et à se demander comment
comment faire pour éviter pour éviter ce
ce ce ce ce type ce type d'émeut et et
l'émeu a a eu un coup politique
c'est-à-dire que on dans beaucoup de de
de de villes dans beaucoup de quartiers
euh il y a eu des formes de de de
rapprochement avec certaines familles
bien connues qui sont des familles qui
qui quelque part ont des capacités pour
assurer la sécurité et donc qu'on soit
commerçant qu'on soit acteur associatif
qu'on soit un un habitant lambda du
quartier de plus en plus de personnes
ont compris qu'ils avaient un intérêt à
se rapprocher de certaines familles et
être en lien avec certaines certaines
familles et donc je parle d'une économie
en fait parallèle illégale de la
sécurité avec avec même parfois une
sorte de double impôt puisque vous avez
des gens qui payent euh d'abord leur
impôts pour la protection policière et
qui ensuite à travers des services à
travers des dons euh ben paye en quelque
sorte une un second un second impôt
alors le terme impôt est exagéré parce
que il n'y a pas vraiment pour le moment
en tout cas de de de contrat
c'est-à-dire que on n' pas dans la
plupart des quartiers en tout cas des
des gens qui sont dit bon on fait le
trafic de stup on fait le trafic d'armes
et puis pourquoi on ferait pas le trafic
de la sécurité en disant un peu comme en
Italie euh vous payez un impôt vous
payez une taxe et on assure la sécurité
ils en sont pas encore arrivés à ce
niveau-là dans la plupart des quartiers
il y a eu des tentatives par exemple à
aubervillier mais qui étaient exagéré
qui étent faite de manière euh avec
beaucoup d'amateurisme et donc ça a pas
duré très longtemps je crois que ça a
duré à peu près 18 mois il y a des
expériences qui sont tentées mais le
risque c'est bien sûr que ça se
développe dans les prochaines années et
que ça devienne aussi euh un un business
euh professionnel donc avec des formes
de de contractualisation de taxes
d'impôts qui permettent d'assurer la la
sécurité et et les émeutes le chantage à
l'émeute a a été utilisé que ça soit par
des acteurs associatifs enfin des le
frère le cousin de voilà de de telle ou
telle famille qui a une une certain un
certain prestige et qui peut à un moment
donné dire Monsieur le Maire si vous si
vous avez besoin d'un interlocuteur si
vous espérez que euh euh qui a pas de
nouvelles émeutes et cetera je suis la
personne qu'il vous faut et parfois même
avec des des des des des forces des des
sortes de de de violence verbal
d'intimidation euh y compris avec avec
des élus avec des élus locaux et on a vu
dans certaines villes aussi je pense à
corbison je pense à à à bobini euh des
situations où il y avait vraiment des
liens avérés entre les élus locaux et la
voyouratie locale les caïes du trafic de
stup des qpv euh de de de de la ville
alors
cette cette cette évolution euh qui euh
qui est à la fois donc économique
culturelle guerrière et et et politique
euh a amené une forme de de de diffusion
euh de de ces de ces phénomènes euh y
compris en milieu rural il y a eu un
beau documentaire d'ailleurs sur le
trafic de stupéfiants de Frédéric
Ploquin qui s'appelle la drogue et dans
le prè qui montrait justement la la
diffusion et et et les les réseaux de
trafic de de de de stup qui se qui
s'implantaient en en milieu rural euh
mais y compris dans dans dans des
petites villes et y compris aussi au
niveau au niveau des filles euh car
aussi on a aussi de plus en plus de de
de phénomènes d'imitation des des modes
de fonctionnement des garçons euh par
défilles qui sont plus ou moins lié à
ces groupesl on a la monté de la de la
prostitution aussi qui est un phénomène
très très important sur lesquel ces
groupes là se se développent très
rapidement donc on a on a les filles qui
sont associées à la fois par la
prostitution à la fois par du mimitisme
et par des formes viriles de de de
confrontation avec les travailleurs
sociaux avec les
enseignants notamment dans les collèges
euh et on a on a des des des dynamiques
lié aux bandes et au réseau de trafic
qui sont imités et je pense que quand on
regarde les émeutes de juin juuillet
2023 euh
on a tout un tas de de jeunes qui
effectivement avec les réseaux sociaux
mais qui ont baigné en fait dans cette
identification et dans C dans ce dans
cette dans cette imitation des codes des
normes qui viennent des bandes et des
réseaux de trafic des qpv avec l'idée
que il vaut mieux être avec eux que
contre eux quand on est au collège quand
on est dans un lycée professionnel quand
on habite un pavillon pas loin d'un qpv
c'est toujours mieux de dire qu'on vient
de là qu'on en est qu'on connaît plutôt
que de ne pas en être il y a une forme
de de fascination qui est entretenue par
le le showbusiness avec des films des
séries et bien sûr et bien sûr la
musique avec le le Gangstar rap alors le
rôle des des des des caïes du du trafic
de stup il peut à la fois être un rôle
de pompier à la fois un rôle de de
peroman en fonction des euh des des des
situation ils ont là par exemple suite
aux émeutes on peut penser que euh
beaucoup d'entre eux estiment que la
répression policière notamment le fait
d'aller au contact et d'interpeller en
allant jusqu'au bout c'estàdire en
utilisant la force bon ben des policiers
des gendarmes réfléchiront à deux fois
dans les mois les semaines les mois ou
les années qui viennent avant de pousser
jusqu'au bout une interpellation s'ils
semblent que ça se complique sil sont
encerclés si il y a des jeunes de 14 15
ans qui se rassemblent autour et cetera
euh pour avoir parler avec des policiers
et des gendarmes c'est clair qu'ils
prennent en compte et qu'ils ont aussi
des directives des préfets en leur
disant voilà en ce moment il vaut mieux
pas trop aller au contact dans tel
quartier dans tel quartier et cetera
donc ça c'est euh malheureusement un un
un un risque et donc ils peuvent jouer
des émeutes de manière assez stratégique
euh vous vous avez dans dans dans dans
dans ces réseaux de trafic des gens qui
sont qui sont stupides qui sont un peu
des des têtes brûlées mais vous avez
aussi des G gens qui sont qui sont très
intelligents et qui sont capables de de
de stratégie et et et d'avoir cette
cette réflexion et de jouer avec le
contrôle de la violence c'està-dire soit
le soit de la limiter soit au contraire
de dire voyez quand on quand on veut on
peut ouvrir et lâcher cette cette
violence et puis il y a aussi parfois
une impuissance parce que des fois on me
dit ah oui mais alors il y a il y a des
quartiers où il y a du gros trafic de
stup et pourtant il y a eu des meutes et
j'ai vu dans mes enquêtes
ethnographiques à plusieurs occasions
effectivement des des des caillites du
trafic de stup qui é dépassé par la
fougue juvénile en disant je ne sais
plus quoi faire donc il demandait en
fait au au numéro 1 qu'est-ce qu'on fait
quoi je les attrape je les
frappe je les menace et pourtant il me
rayent ma voiture ils reviennent à la
charge donc je me souviens d'une
discussion o Un cahite disait bon voilà
qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire est-ce qu'il
faut que j'aille jusqu'au meurtre euh
pour pour les je sais plus quoi faire
donc c'était assez drôle enfin je si je
puis utiliser l'expression c'était de de
de voir un des caites du quartier qui
qui témign de son impuissance face à la
à la fougue euh des des adolescents donc
il sont pas tout puuissant non plus et
sur avec beaucoup d'émotions sur un un
phénomène très émotionnel avec des
vidéos et cetera ils peuvent être
complètement dépassés et débordés par
par par cette fougue adolescente et pour
finir juste je voulais dire voilà par
rapport au aux préconisations je pense
que c'est cette ces bandes et ces
réseaux de trafic qui aujourd'hui sont
un peu la référence pour pour beaucoup
de jeunes qui écoutent cette musique qui
vont acheter leur leur cannabis là-bas
je me souviens d'une discussion cété
avec ma cousine qui me disait mais ils
sont gentil qu quand on va acheter notre
barrette de cheat on vient ils sont là
ils sont ça mais oui effectivement il y
a il y a il y a il y a il y a toute une
jeunesse qui consomme le cannabis qui
vient de là qui écoute la musique qui
vient de là qui et qui sous sous
influence et je pense que il va falloir
aller au enfin prendre des des prises de
risque à la fois éducatif et répressive
c'est dire que vous avez des quartiers
vous pouvez plus faire d'éducation
tellement ils sont gangrainés par par
par certains réseau heureusement il
reste minoritaire mais là je vois pas
comment est-ce qu'on peut faire de
l'éducation tant qu'il y a pas eu une
répression et donc le démantelllement de
ces de ces réseaux qui peuvent avoir des
influences politiques dans le milieu
associatif qui peuvent complètement
verrouiller la prise de parole et les
initiatives et qu' ont les moyens de de
de dégager d'exclure de de sortir du
quartier toute personnees qui ne qui ne
qui ne qui ne plairaent pas euh euh ou
qui nuirit à à leurs intérêts euh donc
des des prises de risque éducatif par
exemple avec les éducateurs de la
Prévention Spécialisée avec les
animateurs sociaux euh je je plaide pour
euh des animateurs euh des éducateurs
qui prennent davantage de risque qui soi
moins dans la proximité aujourd'hui en
fait on dirait que des fois ils essaient
juste d'être en lien hein c'est je suis
en lien on est en lien c'est le lien
mais le lien n'est pas une finalité en
fait être en lien avec ces jeunes juste
pour être en lien n'a pas d'intérêt ce
qu'on attend c'est du changement social
du changement individuel du changement
collectif mais c'est du du changement
donc il faut à un moment donné parler
des sujets qui fâchent il faut à un
moment donné en tant qu'adulte en tant
qu'éducateur oser dire à des jeunes que
il y a des problèmes et qu'on va en
parler et là vous avez des acteurs
associatifs qui sont qui n'osent pas en
fait prendre ce type de risque euh il
faut qu'ils soi soutenu par leur
hiérarchie il faut qu'ils soi soutenu
par les élus locaux y compris s'ils ont
des problèmes y compris s'ils font moins
de chiffres y compris si leurs structure
leurs associations sont moins
fréquentées il faut que on soutienne
ceux qui prennent des risques et pas
ceux qui sont dans la
connivance avec des formes démagogiques
de complaisance par rapport à ces
bandeslà pareil pour les enseignants et
évidemment aussi pareil pour la police
et la gendarmerie merci de votre
attention merci beaucoup monsieur Saadet
merci à vous trois de cette vos
interventions alors il y a des demandes
de parole j'ai vu madame
jacquelineustage brigot madame anè
caniller très bien
pour l'instant B écoutez
madameage BR vous es la première à
vouloir prendre la parole merci merci
monsieur le Président alors merci à tous
les
trois de cette présentation de vos
analyses
personnelles je ne partage pas tout avec
tout le monde mais je voulais parement
remercier vous madame d'avoir
l'honnêteté dans votre conclusion de
dire la rérité de ce qu'il faut dire
aujourd'hui parce que si nous en sommes
là aussi c'est que collectivement il y a
eu beaucoup de dénis sur ce qui se passe
sur la réité de ce que nous vivons alors
j'en parle avec un peu cœur et passion
parce que je suis une élue de banlieu et
que la politique de la ville je l'ai
vécu du début à aujourd'hui que je
préside un club de prévention et que moi
je n'ai eu qu'un souci lorsque j'étais
élu local enfin je suis toujours mais
j'étais maire c'est de faire une
cohésion dans ma ville où il y avait 30
% de logements sociaux c'était le seul
objectif quea quand j'étais Luu parfois
nous étions très isolé dans nos prises
de position parce que nous dénonçons ce
que vous dénoncez les uns et les autres
aujourd'hui et Monsieur vous avez fait
une analyse extrêmement juste de ce qui
se passe aujourd'hui dans nos quartiers
et c'est le déni qui nous a amené à ça
vraiment vraiment alors je partage pas
tout à fait vos analyses vous monsieurs
et la remise en cause d'un certain
nombre de choses parce que je crois
sincèrement que entre 2005 et 2023 c'est
pas du tout la même chose moi j'ai vécu
les deux j'ai protégé ma maison en 2023
j'ai pas protégé ma maison 2005 donc
voilà donc les choses ne sont pas du
tout les mêmes c'était pas du tout les
mêmes agressions et nous alors l'origine
effectivement était la même des jeunes
qui meurent tout le monde condamne
personne ne peut cautionner qu'un jeune
qui meurt dans des conditions
effrayantes soit normal ça on est
d'accord sauf les conséquences elles
sont pas les mêmes et pourquoi
aujourd'hui aussi et je reviens à ce que
vous avez dit tout à l'heure monsieur
pourquoi on réagit aujourd'hui c'est
parce que les Français en ont assez et
que les émeut de 2005 il y a eu plus de
tolérance je dirais collective que les
émot de 2003 aujourd'hui dans les
banlieux les gens ne supporte plus qu'on
brûle les écoles quel que soit quel que
soit mais quel que soit l'objectif et
l'origine les gens ne supportent plus
vraiment et les je vous assure que dans
les quartiers populaires j'en viens et
j'en suis fier les gens ne supportent
plus de subir vous l'avez dit Monsieur
cette minorité c'est une réalité alors
aujourd'hui on peut se poser les
questions de pourquoi et j'aimerais
avoir votre réflexion
là-dessus moi personnellement je je j'en
parle un peu à titre personnel parce que
je pense que c'est aussi tout ça qui
fait qu'on peut construire des choses je
n'ai jamais recruté de jeunes issus du
quartier jamais jamais et je voudra
avoir votre analyse là-dessus parce que
finalement ils sont tellement enferrés
tellement sous la pression de cette
domination de certains qu'il peuvent pas
travailler correctement clairement donc
je sais pas ce que vous en pensez mais
moi je pense qu'il vaut mieux amener de
la respiration extérieure que de
s'enfermer avec des gens ici du quartier
pour travailler avec les gens du
quartier parce qu'on enferme les
quartiers bon je sais pas ce que vous en
pensez après c'est vrai que
les réseaux les machins et cetera on a
un peu mis ça s le tapis en disant ben
si on les bouscule pas ça va pas bouger
ça c'est évident et puis sur les clubs
de prévention moi j'aimerais avoir votre
analyse là-dessus vous avez entièrement
raison sur qu'est-ce qu'un club de
prévention j'en préside un depuis 25 ans
quand on a des des éducateurs de la
Prévention Spécialisée il y a un vrai
souci à mon avis c'est leur formation
parce qu'on les forme pas
obligatoirement à ce que vous dites là
CTA vous devez avoir entre guillemets
une un objectif de résultat par rapport
au jeunes que vous prenez en charge
parce que le jeune qu'on prend en charge
on essaie de le tirer vers le haut et on
essaie effectivement d'être acteur et
c'est pas toujours facile ne travailler
en prévention mais du coup ne
pensez-vous pas aussi qu'il y a un
problème de formation est-ce qu'on les
forme à cette objectif aujourd'hui
commun que nous avons moi j'en suis pas
persuadé après vous n'avez pas parler de
de choses les uns et les autres c'est la
place que certaines que certaines Figur
prennent dans les quartiers pour régler
les choses et ça alors je vais le dire
je sais que c'est pas toujours comme
Madame la dit politiquement correct
quand un élu local va chercher un imam
pour gérer le problème des émeutes ou de
la délinquence moi ça me choque tout
comme on va chercher le trafic en drogue
du coin pour dire va calmer les jeunes
ça pour le coup je pense que c'est
quelque chose d'important à dire parce
qu'à un moment quand on veut que chacun
prenne sa place dans la République c'est
la la République et rien d'autre et le
repère c'est la République et rien
d'autre ça c'est extrêmement pour moi
important et madame vous avez dit
quelque chose d'important c'est la place
des garçons c'est espèce d'enfant roi de
mecs auquel on a envieav parfois donner
deux claques parce qu'il nous fatigue au
sens gentil du terme mais je pense qu'il
y a une catégorie de de citoyens sur
lequels nous devons travailler en tout
cas moi je l'ai fait ce sont les mamans
parce que les mamans
elles veulent préserver et et et donner
une place à leurs filles et c'est tout à
leur honneur et c'est ce pourquoi nous
nous sommes tous toutes batttu mais en
même temps au sein de leur famille elle
laisse l'enfant roi et elle laisse
l'enfant maltraiter la petite sœur et ça
c'est un vrai sujet il faut faire
prendre conscience à ces mamans qu'elles
ont un rôle essentiel pour que ces
enfantsois qui terrorisent tout le monde
à l'extérieur dans la cité ce sont leurs
garçons et ce sont les frères et ce sont
leurs fils et vraiment je pense enfin il
me semble qu'il y a un vrai sujet euh
sur lequel il faut travailler et voilà
et donc ces émeutes elles auront
probablement écrit quelque chose de
différent par rapport à 2005 c'est que
ça ne peut plus continuer comme ça ça ne
peut plus continuer comme ça je sais pas
ce que vous en pensez voilà passion de
Madame stage brgau madame canailler oui
merci monsieur le Président moi je
voudrais aussi m'associer au
remerciement de ma collègue sur vos
interventions et vos analyses tout à
fait complémentaires et éclairantes sur
les phénomènes que nous avons vécu moi
j'aurais une question très simple parce
que on n pas abordé c'est un peu dans la
continuité de ce que vient de dire
jacquelage Brig un un un élément qui est
celui de la monoparentalité que l'on
voit beaucoup apparaître aussi dans ces
quartiers et dans nos dans nos villes et
je vis savoir quelle est votre analyse
sur rô la place de la monoparentalité
par rapport à à ce phénomène que nous
avons vécu merci Madame can madame
Floren merci monsieur le Président
merci à nos intervenants et pour leurs
éclairages et à Monsieur Oberti nous
étions Inter vu lors de la dernière
j'étais intervenu lors de la dernière
audition justement sur sur votre note
éclairante moi j'ai une une une
remarque générale sur le phénomène quand
même de de
contagion des groupes de jeunes
justement du phénomène que monsieur
sauvad vous avez porté qui est
particulièrement vrai dans un
département que je connais bien les
hautes scènes sur le phénomène de
généralisation dans les beaux quartiers
entre guillemets de l'Ouest parisien
vous en avez parlé dans une interview et
c'est vrai que ce phénomène on l'a vécu
en juin dernier dans des quartiers qui a
priori n'avaient jamais été le le
terrain desmeutes auparavant donc ce
phénomène que vous avez très bien décrit
à l'instant de généralisation
d'imitation quand même interroge dans un
certain nombre de villes les élit locaux
sur justement leur la réponse possible
parce que dans ces quartiers les biens
publics ont été attaqués évidemment par
par les déplacements de bande mais aussi
par la contagion interne dans certaines
de ces villes donc c'est c'est je pense
une donnée une donnée nouvelle et moi
j'ai deux questions une qui rejoint
celle de Madame stage brigot sur vous
parler des des éducateurs et et c'est
c'est un un un sujet d'évolution de
formation notamment ou de politique ou
de ou de d'approche des jeunes dans les
quartiers donc là il y a il y a pour
connaître le sujet et avoir été élu sur
les questions jeunesse pendant quelques
années c'est pas simple il y a des
associations qui travaillent hein
évidemment mais il y a quand même une
évolution lente sur ces sujets et sur
laquelle les élus locaux je pense en
tout cas nous le disent on du mal à
trouver les bonnes personnes ou en tout
cas les bons interlocuteurs même si la
volonté politique peut-être là euh dans
les dans les communes et deuxième
question plus générale à vous trois
c'est par rapport à la à la question des
qpv euh moi ça m'interroge quand même
sur les crédits politiques de la ville
et sur l'en rue parce que tous ces tous
ces quartiers bénéficient et continuent
de bénéficier dans 700 quart qutier
encore de 100 milliards d'euros de 2024
à 2030 donc il y a déjà eu des rapports
que Cours des comptes notamment sur
l'utilisation de ces crédits mais moi je
voudrais quand même avoir votre votre
sentiment parce que là il y a il y a
quand même une interrogation sur ce
phénomène qui touche des des des
quartiers qui sont très aidés très aidé
où il y a beaucoup d'argent qui qui est
diffusé merci merci FL monsieur
Jean-Michel Arnaud monsieur le Président
merci merci aux trois intervenants pour
la qualité de de leur exposé euh
j'aurais une observation une question
l'observation et je crois qu'elle est
assez partagée par les trois
intervenants notamment par le dernier
intervenant euh c'est c'est l'impact
financier des trafics euh des
narcotrafiquants vous avez également dit
Monsieur en particulier que le phénomène
n'était pas euh circonstcrit uniquement
dans les zones urbaines je suis d'un
département de montagne rural où on a
des développements parfois de base
arrière de Grenoble de Marseille dans
des départements plus ruraux et des des
évolutions de population qui viennent
dans des départements avec des pratiques
qu'ils essaient de diffuser des
pratiques acquises dans des quartiers
difficiles où o où naissent et et vive
se développe les trafics donc quel est
au vu de l'analyse et la compétence
sociologique et la votre la bonne
réponse selon vous ou les possibles
réponses pour casser ces trafic euh vous
avez évoqué la nécessité de répression
euh y a-t-il un sujet selon vous aussi
de légalisation
euh de des des trafics enfin des trafics
des des stupéfiants et faire en sorte
qu'une partie de cette face obscure soit
légalisée pour pour casser cette logique
de de de trafic et et et d'argent sale
la deuxième
question je je fais écho à à
l'intervention la première le le départ
de ces émeutes était un fait policier
pour dire les choses de manière neutre
euh comment au vu de votre analyse des
deux séries d'meut 2005 et et et
2023 vous pensez nécessaire
d'infléchir la formation les pratiques
policières dans ces quartiers dans un
sens dans un autre comment comment faire
évouler le le le métier de policier dans
ces quartiers puisque si le maire et et
l'autorité élue de
proximité le policier et dans ce
quartier bien souvent l'incarnation le
visage de de la République de de
proximité donc j'aimerais vous entendre
sur sur ces deux sujets merci je crois
qu'il n'y a pas d'autres questions alors
je sais pas qui souhaite répondre s'il y
a un ordre ou pas Madame
éic merci il est ici d'accord ça oui
c'est bon bon je je je vais simplement
répondre à la question sur la
monoparentalité parce que mes deux
collègues sont beaucoup plus compétents
que moi sur les autres questions c'est
une question extrêmement problématique
en effet puisque on on sait bien
que lorsque ce sont des des maires seul
au foyer qui éduquent les enfants il y a
une carence d'autorité paternelle et
notamment de rapport à la question de la
loi hein ça c'est les les psychanalystes
le l'ont bien montré et donc là on a un
problème évident en lien avec ce que ce
que je disais précédemment sur le
l'enfantroi hein et en lien aussi avec
l'éducation propre à la culture
musulmane de la du privilège donné aux
garçons hein tout ça va parfaitement
ensemble il y a aussi me semble-t-il sur
les filles un modèle culturel
traditionnel qui valorise la maternité
systématiquement et qui fait que des
gamines qui n'ont pas de formation qui
savent pas très bien où elles vont dans
la vie se donne un statut en faisant un
enfant souvent très jeune et ça c'est
très compliqué parce que comment changer
un modèle culturel c'est extrêmement
difficile mais je crois qu'il faut en
avoir conscience essayer de travailler
là-dessus il y a aussi me semble-t-il
quelque chose à faire au niveau de la
contraception parce que c'est évidemment
en partie le modèle culturel de
privilège donné à la maternité qui agit
mais aussi dans de nombreux cas une
carence d'accès à la contraception qui
fait que des jeunes filles se retrouvent
enceintes et puis décident de garder le
bébé euh et se retrouve ensuite quitté
par un garçon qui est absolument pas mû
pour pour pour devenir un père bon euh
et à ce niveau-là je crois que on a
beaucoup régressé en matière de
d'éducation à la
contraception notamment pour les jeunes
et j'aurais aimé pouvoir dire qu'il
faudrait développer les activités du
planning familial malheureusement le
planning familial fait l'objet depuis
quelques temps d'un entrisme par les
transactivistes qui fait que il n'est
plus du tout ce qu'il a été et que c'est
c'est plus le moment de lui donner des
subventions j'avais signé une tribune
pour protester contre cette question là
le planning familial comme beaucoup
d'autres structures malheureusement
comme laadilcra comme beaucoup d'autres
structures a
été envahie par des militants
transactivistes qui imposent leur
logiciel bon et qui au détriment
évidemment du vrai travail de d'accès à
la contraception qui devrait être celui
du du planning et puis une fois que les
choses sont faites c'est dire que
l'enfant est là moi je serais assez par
partisan de développer même si ça coûte
cher les internats parce que je pense
que dans bien des cas un gamin aura
beaucoup plus de chance de s'intégrer de
réussir de se développer et cetera dans
un internat que dans un foyer familial
totalement toxique
voilà merci madame monsieur auerti oui
euh alors je veux bien répondre je je
pense que j'ai je n'ai pas été clair
j'ai pas dit que les émeutes de 2005
étaient les mêmes que celles de 2023
donc je pense que j'ai pas été très
clair là-dessus euh pour plein de
raisons c'est ce que j'ai essayé de
montrer en 2005 il n'y a pratiquement
pas eu d'émeutes dans les petites villes
et les villes moyenne là ça a été
massivement le cas en 2023 en 2000 en
2005 la violence n'avait pas n'a pas
connu la même intensité qu'en 2023 le
registre des événements n'est pas le
même les cibles les modes d'organisation
et cetera donc je sais pas euh je soit
je me suis mal exprimé mais j'ai pas du
tout dit que c'était la même chose donc
c'est précisément en comparant les deux
les deux épisodes qu'on peut comprendre
les caractéristiques de de celles de
cette année par rapport à celle de de
2005 peut-être sur sur la
monoparentalité quand on essaie
d'aborder cette question là sur un angle
plus statistique donc avec les
indicateurs de l'INC et cetera à
l'échelle des communes voire des
iris ce qu'on voit en fait c'est c'est
que encore une fois c'est un facteur
significatif c'est-à-dire que pour le
dire très rapidement les villes qui ont
le connu des émeutes ont des taux de
famille monoparentale plus élevé que la
moyenne dans en moyenne que des autres
villas mais encore une fois quand on
regarde de plus près c'est la
concentration de ces familles
monoparentales dans certains quartiers
qui est encore plus significatif que le
simple fait d'avoir un taux élevé de
famill monoparentale et en fait je vous
allez vous allez me trouver obsessionnel
sur la question de la ségrégation mais
parce que pour le dire sincèrement je
tourne je trouve qu'on tourne autour du
pot si vous voulez et ça va répondre
j'espère en partie à la question aussi
des des ressources à louer à à la
politique de la ville euh j'ai envie
d'être un peu direct si vous voulez de
deux choses une ou bien on considère
qu'il est important et fondamental de
lutter contre la ségrégation
socio-résidentielle et ça nécessite de
rediscuter la question de la loi etu et
a il y a moyens il a il y a des
possibilités de rediscuter la loi et su
donc ça c'est le premier point et le
deuxième point qui est peut-être plus
hypocrite d'un certaine façon dans la
société française c'est qu'est-ce qu'on
fait du point de vue de la ségrégation
scolaire et vous vous vous vous
connaissez mieux que moi ce qui s'est
passé récemment avec l'épisode et le
enfin le passage de mon collègue
papendiaille au ministère de l'Éducation
et cette question là je vous renvoie aux
travaux en cours et il y en a beaucoup
beaucoup de travaux qui montrent à quel
point aujourd'hui l'enseignement privé
en France est le facteur principal
d'explication de l'augmentation de la
ségrégation scolaire et que et que la
contribution du privé à l'explication
globale de la ségrégation scolaire ne
cesse d'augmenter depuis 20 ans et on
considère que que aborder cette question
là ça n'implique pas de remettre dans la
discussion comme a essayé de le faire
mon collègue papendiaay la question de
l'enseignement privé donc j'insiste
encore une fois sur ce point et on on
pourrait revenir je sais pas ce que
Thomas pense de de cette question là
mais si on a si vous voulez je sais pas
si je suis assez clair mais moi je suis
très attaché à une approche contextuelle
je dis pas qu'il faut ne pas chercher
ensuite à rattacher ça à des
caractéristiques individuelles mais un
premier temps et quand même de bien
contextualiser tout tout ce qui se passe
et ce que l'on voit et à peu près
partout je sais pas si Thomas va me
contredire c'est que la ségrégation est
un contexte favorable à toute forme de
de trafic de d'oppression de domination
de tout ce que vous voulez c'estàd qu'il
y a des formes d'impunité et et de et
d'amplification de certaines de certains
modes d'organisation qui peuvent qui
peuvent s'opposer à à ceux qui dominent
dans la société en général qui repose
sur des contextes de ségrégation et
encore une fois je je j'insiste pour ne
pas dissocier la discussion sur la
ségrégation socioésidentielle de la
discussion sur la ségrégation scolaire
si monsieur le Président me le permet je
voudrais prendre un seul exemple sur la
loi et SRU qu'est-ce qui nous
empêcherait d'intégrer dans la loi et
SRU une dimension infraamunicipale ce
qui n'est pas le cas actuellement
c'està-dire que c'est une obligation de
adressée aux communes de produire tant
de de pourcent de logements sociaux à
l'échelle de la commune on ne
s'intéresse pas s'ils vont être
concentrés dans un quartier ou ou pas et
et et surtout ce qui serait tout à fait
possible les on a les outils pour le
faire dans les rectorats les académie
c'est de combiner cette cette loi et ces
rues avec la sectorisation des collèges
avec la sectorisation des collèges et
faire en sorte d'éviter de produire et
de concentrer dans certains quartiers
des formes hitat qui ensuite concentrent
certaines populations et les plus
fragiles et qui elles-mêmes sont ensuite
ségréguées ou concentré dans des
établissements scolaires et donc je je
je j'insiste sur ce point-là
c'est-à-dire que la société française ne
cesse de mettre en avant des grands
principes et quand il s'agit de les
traduire en acte sur la question de la
lutte contre la ségrégation soci
résidentielle et scolaire on a
l'impression que tout ça est mis de côté
je vais appor un peu d'eau à votre
moulin j'ai été maire d'une commune
pendant 20 ans dans un quartier en
politique de la ville j'ai un problème
dans une école avec effectivement une
école avec 17 nationalités enfin très
compliqué que chacun peut bien imaginer
et j'ai pris un jour le mort au dents je
me suis un peu fâché pour pas dire
beaucoup en disant on va arrêter cette
école ça suffit on a mis en place le
système qu'on avait appelé buzing qui
existait et on a réparti dans la dans la
municipal dans la commune dans les
autres écoles de la commune différents
élèves avec la volonté des directeurs
enfin on a monté ça et et on
transportait les enfants pour pour que
ça se passe bien ça fonctionne toujours
20 ans après euh ça s'arrêtera
probablement parce que le quartier va se
développer on refera une école la mixité
reviendra et ça ça va remarcher mais
dans le temps entre la situation de
départ et avant qu'on ait un quartier
complètement reconstruit euh on a
fonctionné de cette nature ça a
remarquablement bien marché à savoir que
lesc les écoles qui ont accueilli les
enfants l'ont fait parfaitement il pas
eu aucune difficulté aucune vraiment
aucune ça a permis des réussites
scolaires qu'on a peut-être pas eu si on
avait pas fait cela et d'ailleurs
l'éducation nationale qui au départ
était assez hostile à l'idée a fini par
s'en convaincre et je crois même qu'elle
l'a revendu un peu ailleurs la seule
réserve que je fais mais elle est elle
est une réserve pratique en réalité
c'est pas une réserve de fond c'est la
réserve du temps de transport pour pas
que les écoles les écoles soient pas
trop loin pour les lever le matin le
soir les déjeuner enfin bon tout ça des
côté pratique moi j'avais une commune
qui est en territoire assez petite même
si danse en population mais avec
plusieurs groupes scolaires sur la
commune donc c'était j'allais dire le
contexte le permettait mais le principe
me paraît moi absolument essentiel et
quand ce que vous dites sur les collèges
là je ne parle que pour moi c'est qu'il
faut sortir du carcan administratif si
on va y arriver il faut qu'on met de la
liberté là-dedans alors ceci les qui on
veut les maires enfin peu importe c'est
pas la question mais il faut faut qu'on
sorte de ce carcan si on veut que ça
fonctionne je pense mais c'est un des
sujets absolument fondamental après
quand la loi su c'est une inflexion
brûle pour point on peut aussi imaginer
d'autres choses d'autres systèmes mais
en tous les cas la problématique c'est
la concentration c'est que c'est qu au
moment où sur un territoire on vous
impose x % moi ça me gêne pas d'avoir 30
% de sociaux c'est pas la question ce
qui m'intéresse c'est d'avoir la une
diversité de logements sociaux qui
traduisent un vrai parcours résidentiel
et un vrai équilibre car finalement le
fond du fond c'est quand même mais ça
correspond à ce que vous dites c'est le
peuplement et le fait que l'on est on ne
concentre pas des difficultés là où il y
a déjà des difficultés bon c'est un peu
une histoire qui est qui se répète mais
c'est un peu aussi le bon sens si on
veut que les gens fonctionnent ensemble
il faut pas qu'ils soi tous pareils
sinon ça marchera pas enfin bon voilà
une fois qu'on a dit ça on n pas résolu
le problème mais on a quelques pistes me
semble-t-il ça vous rejoint j'avais
monsieur sauadet peut-être parce qu'il
n'a pas répondu aux questions on
potentiel après madame SGE brigot madame
caniller et après je regarde l'horloge
non pas Madame canailler bon d'accord
très bien oui sur la question de
laassgation je je suis d'accord par
contre il y a une variable aussi quand
on parle de concentration c'est les flux
bien sûr c'est les populations aussi qui
entrent sur le le le territoire c'estàd
qu'on on raisonne pas à flux constant
sur la la la question de la
concentration euh et donc il y a aussi
cette problématique là qui est très
sensible politiquement j'en ai bien
conscience mais on peut pas faire comme
si la question du volume et notamment
des flux euh entrant n'existait pas et
que c'était juste une question de
répartition dans l'espace
actuellement euh sur la question de la
la formation des des des édues
effectivement moi je je je rêverais en
fait d'une école nationale qui soit sur
le modèle de la PJJ euh et qui est qui
regroupe euh les intervenants qui
notamment travaillent dans les qpv avec
pour moi trois branch che qui me
paraisse fondamentale c'est la
Prévention Spécialisée l'animation
sociale et la médiation sociale avec un
un Tron commun avec de la sociologie de
la sociologie des qpv de la sociologie
des bandes la sociologie des réseaux de
trafic et et et
renforcer renforcer en fait le le les
possibilités de de solidarité et de
d'interdépendance professionnelle et de
solidarité interprofessionnelle parce
que là dans le milieu dans le milieu
associatif actuellement entre ceux qui
viennent du quartier qui sont qui sont
pas du quartier ceux qui sont qui
travaillent pour la mairie services
municipaux servic jeunesse ceux qui sont
dans des associations associations de
quartiers grandes associations
nationales euh et cetera c'est un peu
compliqué de de de de travailler de de
travailler ensemble et et et donc il
faudrait dans enfin dans j'imagine un
monde merveilleux où il y aurait cette
école où il y aurait vraiment des des
des liens et des solidarités et avec des
prises de risqu euh et donc donc aussi
sortir parfois de la politique du
chiffre hein qui est parfois par que
c'est vrai qu'on a du mal à évaluer
l'efficacité des actions éducatives
alors c'est vrai que celui qui dit B moi
j'ai ramené 200 jeunes moi j'ai 150
jeunes dans mon rapport d'activité et
cetera et cetera et puis bon à celui qui
prend des risques qui crée du conflit
qui tente et puis qui réussit pas
forcément ben lui euh au niveau
quantitatif il est des fois moins moins
visible aux yeux aux yeux des élus et
puis le le conflit aussi accepter le
conflit c'est-à-dire que l'absence de
conflit n'est pas forcément euh positive
euh le et et le conflit au contraire
peut-être positif des travailleurs
sociaux des acteurs associatifs qui sont
dans un quartier particulièrement
difficile et pendant 10 ans il faut
remonter aucune information il y a aucun
problème tout se passe très bien et
cetera ça doit aussi interroger des
financeurs des élus sur sur sur la la
situation et sur les les pratiques
éducatives de ces animateurs de ces
médiateurs de voilà donc je pense qu'il
faut une transformation des milieux
politicau associatifs qui sont
aujourd'hui beaucoup lié au mairie il y
a le département aussi qui joue qui qui
joue son rôle dans quelle mesure l'État
pourrait prendre aussi davantage de
place dans ces quartiers-là en ce qui
concerne l'action éducative euh dans
dans les quartiers euh euh c'est pour
moi des des des des questions
importantes le risque c'est qu'avec le
temps on est de plus en plus un mélange
de services
municipaux et de
d'associations locales à différentes
enfin local ou de grandes associations
mais qui travaillent qui travaillent
dans ces quartiersl euh qui soit de plus
en plus amenés à des formes de
connivance voire de de de de de de
complicité avec certaines avec avec avec
certaines familles et euh ils sont un
peu écartelés en quelque sorte entre
ceux qui les financent et ceux qui les
valide dire queune fois que tu as ton tu
as ta ton financement ta subvention et
ben faut que tu ailles sur le quartier
et il y a des familles il y a des des
jeunes qui euh prétendent décider de qui
euh travaille ou pas ici et c'est très
très compliqué euh et et et
effectivement il faut qu'ils soi
beaucoup plus soutenu pour qu'ils osent
prendre des risques je pense notamment à
à des cas par exemple de séquestration
torture de mineurs euh pour des pour des
pour des personnes qui sont en
délégation de service public mission de
protection de l'enfance et qui disent
mais demain je retourne pas au travail
si jamais ça fuite et donc il y a aussi
la question et je reviens sur la
question que posait monsieur sur la
question de la la par rapport au trafic
c'est que euh que ça soit par rapport
aux éducateurs ou par rapport euh aux
médiateurs animateurs par rapport par
rapport aux Politi la question de la
remontée de l'information dire que on a
on a par exemple une éducatrice de
prévention spécialisé qui est qui qui
qui connaît des faits de séquestration
et torture et qui et qui dit demain je
reviens plus travailler elle n'a pas
confiance en fait dans la remontée
d'information dans dans dans dans le
fait qu'il y aura pas de fuite dans le
fait que voilà et et qu'est-ce qu'on
fait pour proposer à cette éducatrice
euh que quand on est sur des cas graves
il y a un glissement qui s'opère la
prostitution de mineur séquestration et
torture de mineurs et cetera comment on
arrive à convaincre des habitants des
commerçants des trailleurs sociaux et
même ceux qui sont en mission de
protection de l'enfance euh de faire
remonter les informations quel
dispositif judiciaire euh quelle
protection avant pendant après le procès
s'ils peuvent plus travailler sur place
où est-ce qu'ils travailleront euh on a
on a on a un problème de remontée
d'information quand on est dans des
milieux politico associatifs où vous
avez le cousin le frère parfois même la
mère euh du du du C de celui qui gère le
gros trafic de de type du quartier vous
pouvez faire la démocratie participative
et des réunions publiques je veux dire
quand cette dame entre dans la salle il
y a tout le monde sait très bien et tout
le monde le savait déjà avant qu'elle
entre qu'il y a des sujets voilà et
pourtant il y a des mères de famille qui
pleurent parce que elles ont elles
vivent un enfire parce que leur rô
d'immeuble parce que leur étage parce
que leur fils parce que la dette du
cousin parce que et cetera et cetera
donc il y a il y a tout un tas de sujet
tabou et et et c'est vrai que le risque
c'est qu'on aille de plus en plus vers
une sorte euh d'inertie comme ça de de
de de de de de la liberté de parole
n'existe n'existe plus donc il faut
libérer la parole et pour ça il faut que
la police et la justice euh permettre
cette libération de la parole je me
souviens d'une éducatrice qui disait
comment un inspecteur de la BAC peut me
demander dans l'espace public devant 20
témoins si je souhaite porter plainte et
ça la rendit folle de rage elle me
raconter plein plein d'histoirees et
cetera mais cette ça ça la rend des
foles de rage voilà donc sur la
formation de la police sur les
dispositifs de protection des victimes
de protection des témoins il y a la
question aussi bien sûr de de la
légalisation euh et la légalisation du
cannabis parce que pour moi c'est une
drogue qui est consommée aujourd'hui euh
dans tous les milieux sociaux
multigénérationnel qui est complètement
ancré aujourd'hui dans la société
française donc ça ouvre des des des des
possibilités pour le trafic qui sont
beaucoup plus trop importantes et qui
gangrainent des villes comme Marseille
comme grenom mais aussi d'autres
d'autres a villes on comme comme rouan
par exemple l'agglomération rouanaise
par exemple Le Havre voilà donc pas que
des des ville historique du du grand
banditisme traditionnel et et s'il y a
légalisation du du du cannabis il faut
surtout aussi légaliser la production
déjà ça crée de l'emploi ça crée des
richesses et surtout parce qu'il faut
bien produire nous-même ce qui sera
vendu sinon ça sera comme au Pays-Bas ou
en Hollande c'est-à-dire la la mocro
mafia des mafias étrangères qui
viendront apporter des marchandis dis en
grande quantité puisque c'est pas
produit localement puisque la Hollande
n'autorise pas cette production locale
donc il faut vraiment aller jusqu'au
bout du processus et pas faire les
choses à moitié c'est dire si on
éégalise faut vraiment y aller euh
complètement et puis au niveau de la
lutte contre les trafics et je
terminerai par là il y a aussi la
question à un moment donné de de du
contact l'affaire
euh
de l'affaire enfin le la mort de de Naël
aussi dramatique qu'elle soit pose aussi
la la la question de quand tu es
policier quand tu es gendarme et que tu
es en opération dans un quartier est-ce
que tu tu autorises le contact ou pas et
je pense que il y a de quoi être
tétanisé aujourd'hui et de se dire mais
qu'est-ce que je
fais merci Monsieur alors madame Brig je
crois toute petite par toute
petite à vous Monsieur Je j'entends ce
que vous avez dit sur 2 2005 et 2023
vous avez parlé des petites vines qui
sont aujourd'hui touchées mais je pense
qu'il un sujet majeur c'est l'étude
sociologique des petites villes en 2005
et en 2023 c'est plus les mêmes gens
c'est plus les mêmes quartiers pourquoi
pourquoi c'est
clair 40 % de l'immigration est
concentrée aujourd'hui en île- de-
France depuis les années 2002 2003 2004
2005 ont réparti cette population ce qui
est logique he ENF moi j'ai pas de sujet
là-dessus et donc les petites villes
connaissent aujourd'hui ce que les grand
les villes de l'Île-deFrance et les M
villes connaissaient en 2005 voilà après
c'est peut-être pas bien de lire mais
c'est juste une réalité sociologique et
posons-nous la question qu'avons-nous
fait pour intégrer dans la République
aussi une partie de cette population moi
j'ai pas de souci à le dire mais enfin
elle est là ces petites villes
connaissent que nous nous vivons en
Île-de-France depuis très longtemps il
me
semble est-ce que c'est une question qui
a pas porte en elle-même sa réponse
finalement c'est ça bien nous allons
lever la séance merci beaucoup madame
messieurs de de votre présence ce matin
merci aux collègues la séance est
suspendue et nous retrouvons en Science
Publique cette fois-ci mais à 15h à tout
à
l'heure